salut j'ai chopé un nouveau casse-tête
boîte réalisé en très peu d'exemplaires
c'est le puzzle box e3 difficultés
annoncées ça que sur six et en plus je
suis plutôt content que ce soit une
boîte à ouvrir moi j'aime bien et je
crois que vous aussi vous aimez ça vous
pouvez me dire dans les commentaires
mais on a la sensation avec loïc que
vous préférez les boîtes dans les casses
têtes cette vidéo en plus et en
partenariat avec audible la plateforme
qui permet d'acheter et d'écouter des
livres audio je vous en reparlerai plus
tard dans la vidéo
loïc angèle eric
[Musique]
c'est là
ce n'est pas
moi
qu'est ce que c'est
[Musique]
alors on va commencer avec la recherche
et l'exploration sur le casse tête mais
certains doivent se dire oui pourquoi il
va parler de l'ibl dans cette vidéo la
réponse est toute simple pour les sous
dans ce bazar de chair parce que comme
je l'expliqué dans mon livre votre temps
est infini j'écoute beaucoup de livres
audio sur la nivelle quand je fais autre
chose et franchement heureusement parce
que souvenez vous que le casse-tête le
plus long de la chaîne m'a pris 17
heures 17h07 et sur une durée aussi
longue ne peut absorber jusqu'à de
livres tout en faisant un casse-tête y
compris mon propre livre votre temps est
un flic qui premier sur dix veulent
depuis quelques mois et sa merci parce
que c'est ouf
et avec l'offre que je vais vous
expliquer après dans la vidéo vous
pourrez même l'écouter gratuitement
on livre ou un autre livre mais le plus
drôle c'est qu'il ya un méta moment à
l'intérieur c'est clair qu'il ya un
endroit dans mon livre audio où
j'explique à quel point il est important
agréable utile d'écouter des livres
audio sur l'a10 belle alors que strass
membres de l'ape vous êtes en train
d'écouter un livre audio sur dix veulent
tu vois le truc ou pas incroyable va
bien c'est fou c'est magique c'est
démentiel je m'en remets pas et moi j'ai
un peu la passion petite flopée de ma
gueule
bon ben ali merci c'est gentil alors
audible c'est ça et bien audible c'est
ça c'est un catalogue de plus de 400
mille titres moi je les utilise
personnellement on peut écouter ça
n'importe où n'importe quand j'ai un
juste écouté par exemple l'art de s'en
[ __ ] je vous recommande ce livre vous
avez le lien dans la description passer
par mon lien pour deux raisons très
important que la première c'est que vous
avez un deuxième mois gratuit au lieu
d'un si vous passez par mes codes à moi
et la deuxième c'est parce que c'est
traquer et du coup c'est bien si vous
passez par mon lien et voilà alors
évidemment quand c'est un casse tête que
je suis me l'a en vidéo il n'y a pas de
livre audio en même temps tout à fait
c'est parti donc puzzle box puzzle box 3
alors je le fais voir d'abord ici il y
avait un petit truc en fait au départ
qui j'espère a priori ne fait pas partie
du casse tête mais je le laissais à côté
il y avait ça qui était comme ça et
quand la reçu c'était décoller et on
voit clairement les points de colle et
je pense qu'avec gpad à chaleur le colis
ou peut-être qui avait pas cette colle
bon bref face à ces foutus de côté c'est
pas très grave mais je le précise c'est
que je ne t'ai tu vois je le précise
puzzle box ces trois là ici les pièces
le côté ça ressemble à ça comment son
exploration sur le dessus on a des
pièces de puzzle et un petit texte en
allemand que je comprends pas ce petit
disque là qui tourne ici vous dirais tu
trouves ça on dirait le logo de
carrefour sanwi oui c'est vrai qu'il ya
un air de carrefour est ce qu'un air de
carrefour c'est un hammam un tintin
tintin
ça a un air d un maire de carrefour
là il ya dérive et qui a priori vont
avons avec ces vies cela mais nous on le
sait on connaît les buy des casse tête
c'est pas parce que ça a l'air d'être
ensemble que c'est forcément ensemble
est ici clairement ça bouge
face à bush il ya un peu de je sais pas
comment vous le dire voilà bah ya un peu
de jeu mais on sent moi je pense que la
boîte elle souffre dc1 clairement en
vrai il ya il n'y a pas grand chose la
con qu'on peut essayer parce que
assurément bas on va pas essayer de
sauver les bouts de plastique qui est
qu'ils sont tenus par les arrivées la
fois que j'essaie quand même parce que
je peux pas m'empêcher ça ça tourne
vraiment dans le vide
mais pas de pas de vices particulier
c'est souvent ça allez casse tête dure
on n'a pas trop les pistes de départ on
sait pas un peu ce qu'on doit faire ou
pas v ouais si quand j'appuie par en
dessous je pense il ya un aimant naquit
juste là là je sens au t1 une attirance
magnétique et comme d'habitude c'est
casse tête sont à gagner c'est à dire
que à la fin de cette vidéo ce
casse-tête sera à gagner sur mon
instagram sous ce poste là qui devrait
être le dernier vous pouvez participer
pour pour le recevoir parce que c'est
quand même des casse tête un peu ouvre
de qualité et en plus en série limitée
donc voilà vous pouvez aller sur
instagram
c'est celui ci on va essayer le
classique souvenez de la panda pandora
box il y avait un truc comme ça on
pouvait comme ça par exemple je crois
que c'est une femme casse-tête loïc
bravo à toi
bon ok on a défait le petit cercle on a
défait ce petit river et est alors le
fait de le défaire c'est assez
incroyable puisque seul ça n'a
strictement rien changé
on a quand même eu des casses t'étouffe
aller taper fort pour mais là c'est pas
possible
si c'est ça c'est nul on a eu à l'
einstein box un coup et c'était réglé
quoi on continue on avance on avance
loïc qu'est ce que je cherche là loïc
toi qui as l'habitude maintenant écouter
exact table alors et mentale moi j'aime
le mental tu aimes mental déjà ma
théorie de il ya un aimant sur la boîte
est complètement confirmée mais là ça ça
doit pas et aimante et du coup il n'y a
pas deux il n'y a pas de puissance pour
le lever ça peut pas être la solution
lui aussi là il ya un aimant ici et
après il ya le cercle 6 1 quand même je
faisais remarquer quand vous faites des
casse tête tu sais que ça c'est trop
épais pour débit c'est ça et pourtant
que dit ouais mais je vais essayer un
petit coup quand même au cas où pour
voir juste voir s'ils le disent qu'ils
pourraient nous servir à quelque chose
j'essaie d'être uqar mais ya pas de
actuellement deux buts
je ressens du champ magnétique
mais si j'ai l'impression qu'un tout
petit truc est monté là juste là sur le
côté a mis un tout petit point
d'aimantation et est-ce que ça a par
contre c'est sûr le sait entre
guillemets sur la même ligne que du be
alors est ce que c'est un résidu de ce
témoin là qui emmène ici c'est possible
bon on va procéder à une fouille
approfondie
loïc selah sue
[Musique]
fabien guerre pas du tout non parce que
figure toi que je vais enlever ça mais
peut-être je les arracher non non non je
pense pas à huy aux hôpitaux en fait il
est clairement retenu par un aimant lui
aussi en fait écouter écouter et
apprécier
je vous le met bien sûr cette caméra
regarde et écoute écoute pas vu à temps
gelé senti attiré aouissi c'est là
d'accord écoute écoute on a entendu la
lémance et sait pas c'est que les clics
ça c'est parce qu'un et mambo ok ok donc
ça mais [ __ ] compris la blague que
valentin de moucherons est ce que ça a
changé quelque chose
ce qu'on peut tout enlever un parent ça
va se voir abandonner en fait je sais
toujours pas si ça va s'ouvrir comme ça
tu as peut-être en tournant un peu et en
déboîtant là il ya un tout petit peu
d'air dahlia entre les deux disques
ouais
côté tourné le carrefour au début sa
dette permise northug est monté j'aurais
pu en bavent en fait là clairement
celui-là regarde on voit que ça c'était
que de la déco maintenant faut voir ce
qu'on peut faire c'est un truc qui me
fait rire dans les cas c'est parce que
je sais qu'en fait vous vous avez
sûrement là des théories parfois avant
moi tu vois et je me dis ça doit être
hyper chose d'être derrière son écran
sur son téléphone ou sur son ordi en
train de se dire mais [ __ ] mais basim
fait ça mais péta olicard et le fait que
je le fasse pas ça doit vous agacer le
terriblement je le pense après y'a un
truc qui enlève l'agacement tu connais
ou pas tu connais pas c'est ça c'est ce
bouton s'abonner
si vous cliquez sur le bouton s'abonner
ou si vous l'appliquez cette page là ça
vous donnera un bien-être et surtout
vous ça vous permettra de moins raté les
vidéos quand elle sortait surtout si
vous activez la cloche qui est ici tu
sais quoi le second disque à 5 pour
qu'ils aient le temps de le faire à deux
et demi c'est long trois quatre ça merci
beaucoup de vous être abonné à cette
chaîne est un motif
je sais que ces champs je fais que ça
d'essayer de tirer les river mais si je
n'avais pas fait de thaler lui on
n'aurait pas enlever mon petit bonhomme
vous prenez ce que je veux dire mettez
moi dans les commentaires la télé ce que
vous feriez maintenant avant avant qu'on
voit la fin de la vidéo call je pense je
pense qu'il ya plus rien à tirer je
pense qu'il ya un truc a déloqué
quelques pas c'est ça ma théorie la saa
et si jamais vous gagnez pas le casse
tête et que vous voulez quand même
n'oubliez pas je vous met à lire dans la
description qui vous ramène vers ce
casse tête mais je peux pas vous en
promettre qu'il reste parce que c'etait
un
un exemplaire limitée l'édition limitée
donc vous pouvez regarder s'il n'y est
pas ne criez pas dans les commentaires
en majuscules ça m'agace rien lui tu
veux passer un peu dessus tu vas essayer
voir je vous laisse dans de bonnes mains
[Musique]
comme ça on voit si on a des cerveaux
complémentaires ou situées différent de
maurin ferrand un petit jeu genre quoi
c'est un mario c'est ah oui le petit jeu
qui entre les deux disent que la belge a
gelé vue de talent et c'est là que ça va
s'ouvrir
tu crois ma mère regarde comment ça ça
bouge comment on sent des trucs là
j'espère que c'est pas un truc non on
entendrait un mouvement dedans il ya
toujours une bille qui roule un truc à
merci non je me suis dit un truc entre
regardant faire comme quoi c'est bien
des fois de changer son point de vue en
regardant quelqu'un de manipuler à sa
place c'est peut-être pour ça que des
fois vous avez des idées avant moi en
fait parce que vous avez un point de vue
extérieur au problème en fait comme il
ya de l'air ici je vais les mois je
viens de remarquer qu'ils avaient
déficit je me dis c'est peut-être ça
s'ouvre et là c'est moi comme il faut
non je me suis par contre on voit qu'il
ya plein de disques et je dis quel est
l'intérêt de faire plein de 10 pourquoi
il y aurait pas que deux blocs alors ça
peut être pour cacher la fente mais je
me dis peut-être que il ya un disque qui
se poussent tu vois ce que je veux dire
ou pas marin parce que ici là il est
plus renfoncer que là en fait si le
disque adler ici sort légèrement à c'est
vraiment un tout petit coup d'ongle et
du coup ici en regard
il est enfoncée alors est ce que ça
voudrait dire qu'ils sont amovibles les
uns des autres dans ce possible j'essaie
intrigant
[Musique]
tu vois [ __ ] là ça va tout ce grave là
tu l'as tu me tues tu vois là ouais mais
toi tu l'as vue là ici ça pousse et du
coup ici ça sort ok je vais essayer de
le pousser au cul je ne sais pas si je
fais bien aussi je suis en train
d'abîmer banon ça a bien été
il avait en fait bon là là vous le voyez
clairement que ça que la sarre au sort
et que l'ats s'est enfoncée tu vois
comme toi toi tu es habillée en clair tu
vois moi je m'enfonçais salut salut
c'est loïc alors la petite énigme j'ai
plus de sous sur le rush alors que
j'avais pas eu de coupure dans le casque
pendant le tournage
en gros ça ressemble à ça sur le
logiciel mal à fabien il dit qui pensent
qu'il faut pousser sur les petits
rondins de bois parce que ça bouge
et du coup ça le rend pas tout content
l'aï dit qu'ils pensent qu'en poussant
comme ça ça devrait s'ouvrir
ben je je vous laisse avec lui allez
bisous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui est ici craque et comme lui par
contre je peux pas bouger parce qu'il
est fixe à il a deux aimants ok il a un
aimant qui doit être sur le pôle positif
est l'auteur le pôle négatif et c'est
pour ça que ça l'a fait littéralement
sauté parce que c'était style et ça
c'est que ça saute
ouais c'est ça à attendre aux fins coup
il avait un flipper tout c'est cool ça
trop bien et après en plus on peut voir
en cash et des trucs dans la boîte ya du
volume et ou franchement j'ai kiffé tu
la mets toi est-ce que vous avez aimé ça
faudra me dire aussi quand même un
moment donné n'oubliez pas avant de
passer à la suite que vous avez un lien
vers le christ est la description que
vous pouvez le gagner sur mon instagram
dont le lien également sur la
description sous la photo vous avez vu
tout à l'heure parce qu'on va pas
remettre les photos content parce que
comme un faut pas déconner merci à audi
veulent aussi d'avoir sponsorisé cette
vidéo n'oubliez pas de vous inscrire
gratuitement en utilisant mon lien à moi
dans la description là c'est important
vraiment d'utiliser mon livre à moi
parce qu'il ya un tracking dessus donc
voilà je compte sur vous fabien oui j'ai
une petite question mais vous y pose ta
question mon ami alors c'est vraiment
très désintéressé ces jeux vous lessard
les jours les jours tu serais pas là au
bureau par exemple quand tu serais pas
là au bureau c'est bizarre comme
existions non mais c'est parce que c'est
pour après c'est une relation de
confiance entre nous alors le 26 mars je
suis à annecy en spectacle dont je serai
pas là le 28 mars puis en dédicace au
cultura de rennes
en avril je serai pas là parce que je
joue mon spectacle avec les dédicaces à
la fois comme toujours le premier à
saint benoît les 7 et 8 avril en
belgique liège et bruxelles le 9 à
saint-amand-les-eaux le 18 à tour le 24
à besançon 25 à longjumeau puis c'est
quoi le tu sais tu regardes le lien
d'hectares dans la description il ya
toutes les dates où je suis en tournée
ou en dédicace donc où je suis pas
d'accord avec opus merci de ne rien à
très bientôt
ciao